researchers around the world are
hustling to create this test kit the
rapidly spreading new coronavirus has
put test kits at the center of how
infected patients are diagnosed so they
can get treatment quickly but there's
one issue with these nose and throat
swabbing tests the results aren't always
accurate at the center of the epidemic
in Wuhan some people tested negative
only later to find out that they
actually have the disease in the US the
CDC sent out test kits to Public Health
labs that gave inconclusive results in
the verification process the
unreliability of these tests even forced
Chinese health officials to expand how
they classify patients which resulted in
a surge of more than 14 thousand cases
in one day they are now including
results from test kits and other
diagnostic methods like chest scans so
how do these test kits exactly work and
why are there so many problems this
government lab in Singapore has produced
test kits for the country's public
hospitals it's also shipped about 10,000
tests to China dr. Sidney Yee leads a
team that developed them she says most
doctors use a type of lab tests called
rt-pcr which can be used to detect small
amounts of pathogens including viruses
like HIV so this is the gold standard
that's being used what it does is it
actually directly detects the presence
of the pathogen it's pretty easy to use
a doctor collects samples from a patient
by swabbing the nose or throat for mucus
those swabs are then sent to a lab for a
test that detects a genetic material of
a pathogen the sample is first mixed
with reagents in a tube then put into a
machine that duplicates the genetic
material so if the virus exists these
copies will amplify its presence
confirming that a patient has tested
positive for the corona virus dr. yi
says the first place for error could be
at the swabbing stage most of the time
the sampling for kovat 19:00 comes from
throat swab kobe at 19 is actually a
lung infection disease so during the
throat swab really depends on
how much of the pathogen you're able to
capture another place for error is the
time it takes for the sample to reach
the lab the pathogen on the swab is not
going to last for many many hours so
their transportation the logistics is
also important transportation is a huge
hurdle in Wuhan where the city has been
on lockdown since mid January when the
sample gets the lab what is the
infrastructure of the lab that is able
to deal with running tests as well as
the expertise in the experience of the
lab technicians that are running these
tests dr. Yi says the most critical
moment for human error is when doctors
decide to use a test kit for instance
many people have been showing mild
symptoms but that doesn't mean they
don't have the pathogen it's very hard
to make the direct correlation between
what our test kit can be used on which
stage of the disease progression with
respect to how much the pathogen is
present in the patients just how
accurately these test kits are being
used is on trial in Wuhan here hospitals
have been overstretched with limited
resources there are not enough stab to
swab patients and labs are inundated
with the backlog with samples that wait
to be tested they have many many
different steps and different processes
involved in just running a test is not
just with respect to the test kit itself
[Music]